[Musique]
spécialiste des faux cils la
conservatrice lors d'animaux pilote la
transformation du muséum c'est ici
qu'est conservé que sont conservés les
restes du plus ancien au sein via ce
qu'on est retrouvée dans le loiret donc
avec par exemple des vestiges qui sont
pas forcément très visible par le public
mais qui sont extrêmement importants
scientifiquement
ici on a par exemple un bout de
mandibules donc la partie inférieure de
la mâchoire
ils sont datés d'environ 13 milan et
c'est les premières traces d'un humain
qu'on aille à son arrivée en 2017
la paléontologue a bien entendu fondu
devant la dame demande cloud une stèle
néolithique datant de moins 6000 ans
découverte à l'ouest d'orléans
alors ça c'est une des pièces maîtresses
comme c'est un trésor de nos collections
en effet elle était déjà présente et on
la présentera demain sous un angle très
différents on a envie de pouvoir parler
aussi de choses qui ne se voient pas en
utilisant des choses qui se voit et qui
sont remarquables comme la dame de monts
clou en l'occurrence elle servira de
support à un discours sur l'adn parce
que ce qui est intéressant avec ce
spécimen c'est que on a une analyse
d'adn mitochondrial c1 laden très
particulier qu'il est transmis que par
la mer qui cette analyse a été faite sur
ces deux spécimens et a pu montrer que
le petit squelette est le fils de
du grand squelette qui est une femme la
dame de monts toulous est l'un des
quatre cent trente mille fossiles
insectes oiseaux plantes et mammifères
du muséum les collections je les connais
pas de foot et je vous dirais même que
dans l'ensemble du musée on ne les
connaît pas tout précisément c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on mène un chantier
actuellement sur nos collections les
moins connues que sur les collections de
botanique aujourd'hui on a un inventaire
sur ses collections qui est de l'ordre
de 1 à 3%
donc on a encore beaucoup à découvrir et
à redécouvrir dans nos collections
kiara après un intérêt important soit
pour le public mais aussi pour les
scientifiques
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on n'en rapidement beaucoup
de travail sur la partie construction du
parcours le parcours est définie il est
destiné
les scénographes ont rendu leurs plans
maintenant on en est à travailler sur
les audiovisuelle sur les multimédias
sur les manips et sur les images qui
vont illustrer tout ça et l'écriture des
textes que le public verra demain mais
qu'encore un gros boulot et puis il ya
toute la partie collection on a des
collections encore d'autres à restaurer
on a des collections à acquérir donc par
des collectes des dépôts d achat
[Musique]
d'ici là réouverture en 2020 c'est
ichtyosaures aura été restauré un
fossiles de reptiles marins datant de
180 millions d'années acquis par le
muséum au 19e siècle l'une des pièces
phares du futur moment
[Musique]